today's speed round is brought to you by
verizon and let's get right into it
christopher
guys drafted lower than expected the way
we're going to catch this is revenge
tour coming or the slide
was justified let's begin with notre
dame linebacker jeremiah usukuramoa
a guy the browns considered taking in
round one he slipped into round two
they traded up to get him he reportedly
was diagnosed with a heart condition
that apparently contributed to that
slip into round two revenge tour coming
for awuso coramoa or was the slide
justified
well i i'm gonna say slide was justified
you know i'm sure he's pissed off to a
degree
and everything like that that he fell
but i would think that he's
hey that's a real issue it's gonna scare
football teams
so you know there's there's just things
in life sometimes you just gotta take it
on the chin and
you know keep keep trucking keep going
forward and unfortunately yeah that
sucks for abuse of cormal only cost them
a few million dollars
i mean geez i i feel really bad for him
but i think when you talk about head
heart things like that and it's
associated with your name you got to
realize that you might fall a little
uh he's going to be an awesome player
for that team he's a scheme fit too
yeah with that many players just
statistically you're going to have guys
that have health issues and
teams don't want to
make that investment and take that risk
with a guy that's got that health issue
because there's no quicker way to get
yourself in trouble with the owner of
the team
when you've got the medical records that
explain
exactly what the problem is and you
take the chance and there's an issue and
all of a sudden the guy just can't play
anymore remember when nick fairly all of
a sudden had a heart issue and just
didn't play anymore right just couldn't
play
he was the first round pick now it was
after he left the lions but
you just never know when that happens
and you get a guy that just can't play
anymore you have wasted that pick
and all of those picks could end up
potentially becoming hall of fame
players if you use them
correctly look i i think you still find
whatever you can to motivate yourself
yeah right
um and and the guy was you know it
wasn't an issue of his playing that
caused him to fall
and you fall onto a team with a very
good offense a very good defense
you're at a position where you can rack
up a lot of tackles we talked about
defensive rookie of the year yesterday
he's a guy that you'd have to think
about
as a possibility just because you know
he's going to be a presence on that
defense and he's going to have the
opportunity with
genevieve and clowny and myles garrett
in front of him to get to the football
and have some favorable matchups and and
make some
tackles and get some sacks and be a guy
who's noticed yeah and i mean
yes i'm interested to see what they do
with them i really am
because you know we talked about him
before the draft he could be
fred warner darius leonard i don't they
could use them like derwin james he
could be a safety too
i mean he played over the slot receiver
as the weak side linebacker all the time
so
uh he's a very intriguing prospect and
really one of my man crushes from the
draft he was the most
one of the most fun watches of all the
evaluations has
zero care for his body like that guy
that will throw his body through
the wall and we need to go faster
because it's the verizon speed round
mike let's go
that's right but i got one more thing to
say oh quickly the browns made it clear
he is going to be a three down
linebacker right you don't take him off
the field he's gonna be on the field all
the time and we'll see him
doing some of those things that maybe a
safety would do the titans took
pit edge rusher rashad weaver who was on
the program in round
four his slide was a little confusing
now we find out
there was a claim of assault arising
from an incident that happened on april
the 18th
weaver's lawyer calls it false and
reckless you know this could end up
being like
the aaron donald situation where the
video backed up that he didn't do
anything but you go through a few days
of wondering what's up
uh revenge tour coming or slide justify
well i
you know i mean i want to say like both
here that's where it's tough i mean
yeah he's gonna be pissed off and want
to give a revenge tour there's no doubt
about it he was
he was worthy of being one of the top 45
picks of the draft he's one of the best
edge defenders in the draft
so i mean if it is a false and reckless
claim
i you know that's gonna add to him more
of the revenge to her man he's going to
a great spot with the tennessee titans
there
they have a real need for it but yeah i
would think that
as a talented and the specimen he is
that
he's pissed off sure and that he wants
to get revenge
he can't believe he was there on you
know round four but like i don't know
it's a tough one
if he's guilty of these accusations of
course the slide was justified
you deserve it so i guess can i reserve
or
wait a little bit to reserve judgment
here on this one
i think there's a teachable moment that
would apply to anyone else who's in this
situation in the future as you get
within a month or so the draft
just stay home yeah lock yourself in a
bunker just stay home
so there can't be any false accusations
if these are false and reckless
you don't get yourself in a spot where
someone can say you did anything because
you didn't leave your house
for a month just buy a house right top
of a hill
in the middle of nowhere and live there
guys just like some guy i know
patriots took alabama defense attack
christian bar moore in round two we
talked about him earlier how there was
concern about him that was getting out
nick saban
spoke up on his behalf the patriots
trade up to get him
revenge tour coming or sloppy justify oh
revenge tour is coming
revenge tour is coming i mean first off
in the big games against the better
teams that's when barrymore played great
he did so i know whether questions about
maybe his work ethic
things like that well if anybody's gonna
know anything about that
it's gonna be belichick with his
connection to saban
so and he makes the trade up for him and
i think he was you know it's he's
definitely one or the two
top tackles in the draft so i think this
is one of those where he's going to go
to new england they're going to be a
good football team
he's going to be pissed off for sure
sorry liverpool
and it's going to be a revenge tour well
and and saban would not come out and
defend the guy
publicly and put his own credibility on
the line
if it wasn't true they are not afraid at
alabama to tell it like it is it gets
back to the thing from last week
and and but and what did he ultimately
say
but the strength coach wouldn't piss on
him if he was on fire
we played that clip i guess i can say it
if we played saban saying it so i
said it he would say that now he
wouldn't say it publicly
but privately he'd make it known that
this is a guy that didn't work hard
enough the strength coach didn't like
him i didn't like him
unfulfilled potential can't get
motivated not a guy you can trust
he'd told bill belichick all that yeah
the fact that belichick moved up and got
him
tells me that he told bill belichick
some pretty good things about christian
baltimore
raiders took tcu safety trayvon morig in
round two
a third safety drafted some had him
going in round
one revenge toward coming or slide
justified well
that's when i'm gonna go with sly
justified i mean i'm sure him
you know him as an individual and a
player is mad and he wants revenge but
you know there was a guy that hey i
certainly scratched my head a little bit
about when i saw people
mocking him like in you know the early
20s of the draft
there's a lot of coverage skills there
but i think the tackling skills lack
that's the thing that i think probably
ultimately hurt him and why he didn't go
as high as holland
and and grant from central florida
because
there's a physicality element they
brought to the football field that i
think
uh morig was kind of missing in his game
and needs to work on a little bit
all right last one cardinal selected
purdue receiver rondelle moore in round
two revenge tour coming or slide
justification
slides justified he's mike i mean this
guy
if you went from just the pure explosive
element in his freshman year film
he's a top 20 pick in the draft i mean
he can fly
but he hasn't been healthy in two years
so the slide was justified
it certainly was but man like
that was a big time woe potential pick
in the second round
to where you just go that if he's
healthy and the guy that we saw a few
years ago
watch out with him paired up with
deandre hopkins kyla murray and
and the rest of those receivers they got
there in arizona
and one of the ingredients to make a
receiver great getting
left on the board into round two having
to spend that 18 hours between round one
and round two
upset salty that becomes the fuel for
the fire that burns and rages like it
did for michael thomas like it is for
chase claypool so maybe the cardinals
be very happy about that by the way but
the moment they took rondelle moore
that's the moment the door closed on
larry fitzgerald going back to the
cardinals between
signing aj green and drafting rondell
moore there's there's no room at the end
no for larry fitzgerald right and
we're still waiting to hear what he's
going to do with his career maybe he'll
try to take up an olympic event we say
that because dk metcalf
is going to try to run the hundred
inspired by that
we're gonna have a draft of guys we
would peg for an olympic event
we'll do that when pfd live continues
right after this
pro football talk is brought to you by
verizon
built right for business
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports